[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Michel bocage Marchand
directeur du festival à toute heure plus
connu sous le nom de festival Jazz à
toute heure bonjour Jessie alors avant
d'être un festival Jazz à toute heure
est une association quelles sont vos
objectifs au tout au long de l'année
alors ce que nous avons créé lorsque
nous avons créé cette association notre
objectif c'était la création du lien
social par l'organisation d'un événement
musical et donc notre activité c'est
d'organiser un festival tous les ans
pendant 5 weekends tous les vendredis
samedi dimanche si vous êtes invité
justement aujourd'hui c'est pour parler
de la 24e édition du festival à toute
heure qui se déroule donc du 17 mars au
15 avril 2023 pop rock blues et jazz
seront au rendez-vous pendant un mois
dans les Yvelines et en Essonne les
artistes joueront au Mesnil-Saint-Denis
à Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines en passant
par Bonnel Gif-sur-Yvette Yvette pardon
et les Molière pourquoi organiser un
événement qui se déroule dans plusieurs
communes du 78 et du 91 alors on a eu
beaucoup de confiance parce que lorsque
nous avons créé le festival en 1999 il
était uniquement sur
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse et trois ans
après on avait des demandes des communes
avoisinantes nous proposons d'accueillir
le festival et c'est comme ça qu'on est
passé de d'une journée en 1999 à 5
week-end aujourd'hui parce que les
communes souhaitent pouvoir accueillir
un événement de dimension internationale
et faire profiter leur population
d'artistes qu'on voit habituellement sur
les grandes scènes parisiennes et ce
festival c'est également une façon de
faire découvrir finalement d'autres
communes un peu moins connues au
festivaliers tout à fait on est sur le
territoire du Parc Naturel Régional de
la Vallée de Chevreuse on est très
attaché à cette image on est dans la
défense du patrimoine pour ce qui nous
concerne c'est le patrimoine culturel le
patrimoine musical et donc l'association
fonctionne avec des équipes locales
c'est à dire que chaque concert est
organisé par une équipe locale avec un
comité d'organisation bien sûr mais le
lien social il est là il est dans la
convivialité pour
organisé l'événement pour accueillir 82
% de notre public vient du territoire du
Parc Naturel Régional et donc voilà il y
a une espèce de de complicité en fait
entre les spectateurs les artistes bien
sûr et les organisateurs du festival et
quels sont vos ambitions pour cette 24e
édition justement alors on l'a un petit
peu évoqué au début de l'émission ça
s'appelle plus festival Jazz à toute
heure mais festival à toute heure
pourquoi ce léger changement de nom
alors parce que lorsque jazz à toute
heure a été créé en 1999 c'était un
festival 100% pur jazz que j'ai créé
avec André sekarelli donc l'un des
meilleurs batteurs de jazz du monde qui
est toujours dans la programmation on a
toujours 30% de programmation sur le
jazz mais notre programmation c'était
l'argile sur le blues la pop rock le
reggae les musiques du monde la chanson
française et donc
gardez le nom de jazz à toute heure on
est un petit peu embêté parce que
quelque part c'est une marque mais en
même temps on voulait pas que dans
l'esprit du public nous connais pas
encore le festival soit un festival 100%
pur jazz comme les très grands festivals
de jazz qu'on a en France donc on renie
pas du tout bien sûr notre amour pour le
jazz on programme toujours du jazz mais
on programme 70% d'autres styles de
musique donc on a fait le lien entre
jazz et Twitter et festival à toute
heure pour garder le à toute heure qui
nous tient à cœur et qui aussi une
symbolique de l'ouverture d'esprit à
toute heure on doit être ouvert et
ouvert aux autres et ce ne sont pas
moins de 13 artistes qui participent à
ce festival est à l'aise donc sur trois
weekends on va justement parler de la
programmation de chaque week-end les 17
et 18 mars Anna Popovic et championne
Fulton trio seront en concert le premier
est à Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines le
deuxième à Bonnelles alors qu'est-ce qui
attend justement les festivaliers pour
ce premier week-end c'est une belle
image de commencer par ce week-end parce
que il réunit notre logique de
programmation Anna Popovic est une
immense star du blues rock c'est une
guitariste de blues mondialement
reconnue elle est serbe élevée aux elle
fait tous les grands festivals de blues
elle a joué avec les plus grands Jo
Bonamassa Eric Clapton vraiment la crème
du blues donc c'est une tête d'affiche
du festival et de champion de fulleton
bah c'est une jeune anglaise alors on
est sur le répertoire jazz pour le coup
c'est une découverte avec le classique
piano voit basse batterie qu'on trouve
dans le jazz sont propres répertoire
quelques reprises de standard c'est la
loi du jazz et en même temps une artiste
qui est très pétillante voilà qui est
qui est un très très bon contact avec le
public qui est très gai c'est un concert
qui est très gai donc ça va nous faire
un bon début de festival et les 24 25 et
26 mars trois autres artistes sont
attendus alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous les présenter justement en quelques
mots alors le 24 je vérifie parce que on
va accueillir Molly Johnson alors Molly
Johnson c'est une artiste très confirmée
pour le coup qui viendra d'ailleurs à
cette occasion recevoir le titre de
Chevalier des Arts et des Lettres en
France c'est pour ça qu'elle sera en
France et elle a uniquement des concerts
sur Paris et chez nous donc on est en
très content de cette exclusivité alors
justement je vous propose on va écouter
un extrait de mollye Johnson et on va
parler des deux autres artistes juste
après l'extrait
[Musique]
le 24 mars pourquoi finalement avoir
pris cet artiste alors c'est une artiste
qui Élise bien aussi notre évolution
parce que au départ c'était une artiste
de pop musique et puis elle a été
militante très active dans la lutte
contre le sida elle était passée par le
jazz et elle revient à la pop musique
comme on vient de l'entendre donc voilà
ça fait aussi une belle illustration de
notre programmation lesquels quels sont
les deux autres artistes pour les 25 et
26 mars alors pour le 25 c'est une autre
tête d'affiche avec Nathalie Dessay donc
Nathalie Dessay tout le monde la connaît
comme diva de l'Opéra ça a été l'une des
plus grandes cantatrices de la chance de
l'opéra français elle a décidé il y a
une dizaine d'années je crois de
d'abandonner l'opéra elle s'est
reconvertise si je puis dire dans le
théâtre où elle joue régulièrement et
dans la chanson française
sont programmes c'est un hommage à
Michel Legrand donc des chansons que
tout le monde connaît forcément une
chanteuse exceptionnelle c'est une de
nos têtes d'affiche aussi cette année et
le 26 du coup alors le 26 c'est une
découverte encore avec lembellock alors
là on a visé un public très ciblé
puisque c'est un hommage à Léonard Cohen
donc clairement si vous êtes fan de
Léonard Cohen vous allez adorer
forcément comme on le fait beaucoup
maintenant l'artiste s'approprie Léonard
Cohen tout en restant très fidèle à
l'esprit de Leonard Cohen faisait
difficile de s'en écarter quand même et
notamment avec la présence d'un
clarinettiste qu'on retrouve
régulièrement dans les productions
Leonard Cohen et puis bah bien sûr les
textes puissants du poète alors on
poursuit avec le week-end du 31 mars
weekend où il y aura le groupe la musgel
on va également écouter un extrait et on
en parle juste après
[Musique]
jeunesse The Voice quand le sommeil ne
vient pas fatigué d'hier j'irai là-bas à
nos égaux au fond des tasses nos amis et
profondeur un appel du temps qui passe
je laisserai demain sur répondeur
[Musique]
donc le groupe l'amuse-gueule qui sera
donc en concert le 31 mars quels sont
les autres artistes qu'il y aura ce
weekend là alors le 31 mars en camuscule
c'est électro swing c'est on est très
fier de Sam et puis le lendemain le
premier avril on a été on accueillera
Jean-Pierre como qui est l'un des
meilleurs pianistes de jazz français
avec notre parenthèse et karelli et
cette année la carte blanche André se
Cali il a choisi de la dédier un crooner
italien qui s'appelle Walter Richie les
amateurs de Sinatra vont se régaler et
enfin le les 7 et 8 avril Gael busuel et
Brooklyn funk essential seront à
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse qu'est-ce qui
nous attend justement pour ce dernier
jour du festival alors
galbushuay c'est blues rock là aussi
chanteuse guitariste on est dans une
énergie folle et les Brooklyn funk et
sancholes c'est un groupe de funk qui a
déjà une vingtaine d'années qui s'est
renouvelé depuis
alors c'est l'un des grandes stars du
festival cette année en 2021 ils ont
fait la grande scène de Jazz à Vienne
7000 bon voilà ça donne quand même une
belle référence les amateurs de funk le
connaissent ce groupe c'est vraiment une
référence et on l'a évoqué en quelques
mots donc vous avez des artistes
internationaux aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on
peut dire que justement votre festival
est un festival donc déjà international
et qui a une force sur le territoire de
de des Yvelines alors honnêtement on n'a
pas d'artistes des Yvelines issus des
Yvelines cette année je vais pas vous
mentir on a en fait la logique de
programmation elle est de composer une
playlist en quelque sorte qui est la
programmation du festival et donc c'est
plutôt les accords entre les différents
styles de musicaux qui qui sont
recherchés plutôt que de je rechercher
des artistes locaux et on peut de toute
façon retrouver donc toute la
programmation sur votre site jazz à
toute heure.com merci beaucoup Michel
bocage marchand d'avoir été avec nous
sur sensation et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]